paralysée choix
ensemble tout est possible nouvelle
chanson du paysage guyancourt toi un
titre entièrement écrit et interprété
par le conseil municipal des enfants
pour sensibiliser au handicap
on parle d'être tous ensemble tous sont
tous réunis donc ça veut dire que en
chantre et dans ça peut faire ça peut
aider les handicapés à faire comme si il
n'était pas vraiment très handicapée qui
qu'il est comme des personnes normes à
une personne normale qu'on est n'importe
quoi quand et n'importe quoi qu'on soit
handicapé de quelque chose une autre
chose et on est tous ses coups un
véritable travail de composition menée
depuis la rentrée
les six membres du conseil municipal des
enfants ou rédiger les paroles mises en
musique par des professionnels c'est
avec l'école de musique de la ville
qu'ils l'ont chanté devant le public
mon rôle a été principalement de faire
travailler sur le plan vocal les enfants
et de pouvoir aussi
faire travailler la chanson avec mes
élèves de manière à former un groupe
solidaire une solidarité qui a rassemblé
différents acteurs de la ville pour un
même message
[Musique]
constance